這裡是AI101,
全網最幽默的AI新聞,
一名可能單獨行動的操作者,
用一套AI自主滲透測試系統鎖定南韓金融機構,
同期至少9家南韓銀行自行披露或被報導遭鎖定。
最後讓調查者掌握線索的是伺服器開放目錄裡的AI對話和一份身份證偽未明的履歷,
可是被打開的並不是銀行最重要的內扇門,
核心交易照常運作,
出事的是貸款仲介查詢、外勤業務支援這類外圍系統。
大門沒有破
客戶資料卻從旁邊的小門流了出去
從小門漏出去的
可不是幾筆資料而已
光是新韓銀行一家
就確認大約25000名客戶受到影響
漏掉的又是哪些資料
姓名 電話 年收入
還有貸款額度
單獨看好像沒有什麼
但拼在一起
就足以量身打造一套詐騙話術
一通電話就叫得出你的名字
那駭客是怎麼露餡的
資安公司CloudStrike發現
它的伺服器目錄沒有上鎖
裡面有Cloud Code的工作階段
Cloud記憶檔
還有中文寫的提示
像一本沒有合上的工作筆記
這本筆記裡最核心的工具叫RTX
一套開源的AI自主滲透測試系統
能讓一個人指揮多個AI代理分工作業
RTX的說明寫明現個人學習用途
這次卻被拿來濫用
工具再厲害
挑目標的還是人
沒有證據顯示
AI自己選中南韓銀行
目標是操作者決定的
AI只是幫忙偵查滲透
替他跑腿
那操作者拿到資料想做什麼
他問過AI
韓國外卸資料通常在哪裡賣
還有怎麼找Telegram上的交易群
這支持以金錢為動機的判斷
但目前沒有證據顯示資料已經賣出
更有反差的是
同一批RTX成果
他轉頭又叫Claude
寫進一份資安研究員履歷
前一刻還在找地方賣資料
下一刻就包裝成求職陳舊
可是這份履歷也不能拿來認人
同一批記錄裡
一處寫26歲
另一處卻填2007年出生
換算下來大約19歲
年齡前後打架
不能當成真實身份
也因為線索對不上
CrowdStrike只用中等信心判斷
操作者可能說重文
以金錢為動機
CrowdStrike也沒有
把這次行動歸到任何國家頭上
那南韓警方呢
警方桌上是28個IP
分佈在至少12個國家
但大多隻是用來藏身的代理和中繼點
比起這些假面
駭客自己留下的AI
對話和記憶黨
反而成了新的指紋
把兩條線索放在一起看
AI可能讓單一操作者
同時指揮多個代理
做出過去向大型團隊才有的產能
可是留記錄
管伺服器
藏身份的紀律
未必跟著升級
駭客的身份還在查
銀行的賬也要算了
10月19日
五家銀行的行長
要到南韓國會的國證監察
說明連環外洩和自安投資的責任
為什麼守住了核心大門
卻讓外圍系統
成了漏資料的小窗
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息